huh
hello
is
so
yesterday
did you hear that guys
okay
oh
okay
hold up
all right good afternoon my name is
gabriel sterling i'm the statewide
voting system implementation manager for
the state of georgia
here to give you an election update as
we get closer to finding who will win
georgia's 16 electoral votes for
president united states
as
counties have certified their results
and the margin
and as you understand when we get closer
to the certifications and the counties
do the reconciliations they find those
onesie choozy votes that are still out
there so
yesterday when secretary raffles burger
was out there here the
total difference was 14 111 as of right
now about 17 minutes ago the difference
is 14 072.
so as you all know he announced
yesterday that we will be doing a risk
limiting audit
which is the next step in the legal
process that is outlined on this
as i've said since tuesday night and
wednesday that this is all about process
process process and following the law as
written
now risk limiting audit is something
that maybe 12 people on the planet can
explain in a way that actually might
make sense and everybody can understand
it is one of those scientific things
where you can use math to get to a
confidence level that the outcome of the
election is correct as measured through
the system
that is built out to get the votes in in
this particular case
the decision was made to do the
presidential election
uh the press and many times has
mischaracterized the rationale behind
this as caving from trump and their
campaign
there's to be further from the truth
because even before the trump campaign
was talking about the possibility of a
recount or do some recanvassing
we knew that there was a specific
purpose for an audit in the law
and a specific purpose was to instill
confidence in the outcome of that
election
if we had chosen to do what would have
been an easier risk limiting audit
in this case there was only one in the
state that could have been easier and
that was the jungle primary united
states senate
it would have probably undermined
confidence in the act of the
presidential election
the rationale that is the reason we've
chosen to do
this
traditional recount understand there are
two separate and apart
things there is an audit and there is a
recount
two separate statutes two separate sets
of rules
um so we've chosen to do this audit to
instill confidence because
as emile moffatt asked a question
yesterday you've been telling us now for
over a year
that we can trust the counts of these
electronic voting machines
and guess what we stand by that
statement because it is the truth
we anticipate this audit will bear that
out
and yes is there a risk involved with
doing this of course there is
as i said very plainly and very clearly
human beings are the most flawed part of
this process
i guarantee you the numbers will be
slightly different
but at the perspective let me give you
some historical data from something
that's not exactly the same
because it was a recount the state of
michigan in 2016
they were doing a manual recount on all
hand marked paper ballots
and the court stopped them part way
through they got through a little over
two million
and through that uh president trump
picked up about 750
hillary clinton picked about 815 so the
marginal difference was about 100 out of
2.5 or 2 to 2.5 million
votes cast and those were all handmark
paper ballots
in this particular situation we are in a
better situation because
you usually see changes mainly on hand
marked paper ballots because that's
where human beings tend to make mistakes
and in this case it's only about 25 of
our votes about 1.3 million
so we anticipate there will be some
changes this is also a logistical
issue for especially large capitals so
we have hired
some outside groups to help with the
logistics side and another outside group
which has really designed
the procedures and processes we're going
to use and giving out the instructions
which either that they're going out
either right this minute or they went
out earlier we had our first training
call with the counties
this morning at 11 a.m i believe about
an hour and a half it went well
county's a very good understanding of
this and let's give some of the other
outside rules around this
they are to begin tomorrow morning at 9
00 a.m and they are to end
at midnight on wednesday the 18th
so it's all the way through wednesday at
midnight not midnight wednesday morning
midnight
of going from wednesday to thursday so
they have that amount of time we have
figured out the amount of adjudication
sorry the amount of auditing teams they
need
these will be auditors and i know
there'll be questions about this if you
want to be an auditor
you must be a state of georgia resident
and then you have to contact the county
if you want to be an observer you can
contact either your local party if they
are organized
if there is no local organized party in
your county or you can contact your
state party to be an observer
this will be open to the public there
will be observers from both parties
and one other key distinction as the
audit teams are going through the
ballots and making their stacks and
they're doing the thing they do their
stacks
and they will if there's a ballot
they're looking at and they cannot
discern the voter's intent it will be
handed to an adjudication team
they'll be made up of both republicans
and democrats to make the decision as to
what that voter's intent was
so that the there will be a
re-adjudication of those ballots now we
didn't anticipate a high number of those
because there were not a lot statewide
and the vast majority of the ones on the
handmark paper ballot that needed to be
adjudicated
mainly for overvotes was in the united
states senate contest
in the united states president contest
there were very few where there seemed
to be any
issues either people knew who they're
voting for or they didn't now a few
things to talk about numbers
and this goes back towards the
misinformation disinformation situation
we see
both in georgia and across the country
there are about 24 000 people who just
chose to skip the presidential race
that is not surprising in fact it's a
very low percent lower than we
anticipated
people are talking about a differential
between binaural votes or trump votes
and then
the difference between the senate if you
go county by county you see different
differentials as in fulton county as one
example
there were i believe 9 000 more voters
for senator perdue
than they were for the president so all
these things will even out over the
states if you look individually there's
nothing
that very odd or ambiguous about that
another thing we've heard about before
is there's 132
000 voters on the rolls or from the
national change of address
federal law prohibits any mass
list maintenance during an election year
so guess what
we know they're there ncoa says that
they're there there's nothing we can do
because of federal law and if some
senators would go maybe
look at this and help states clean their
list this can help
to make that a process that could be a
lot cleaner and a lot smoother we have
joined
the electronic registration information
center which will allow us to do
a little more consistent list cleaning
to make sure that we have a clean voter
list because a clean voter list is the
beginning
of the bedrock of the foundation of
trusting the final outcomes
um i know that there's many other bits
of misinformation out there
talking about flipping votes and
changing votes and
i'll say this again the hammer and
scorecard that
i was quoting when i talked about this
before chris krebs who is the director
of the cyber security and infrastructure
security
agency under homeland security hammer
and scorecard this is him talking
not gabe talking is nonsense
and a hoax so anybody's claiming that
things are being flipped by a super
secret computer developed by the cia
is just not speaking well speaking
nonsense i guess i'll quote chris on
that one
so the procedures around the uh
audit is we have to get through by those
days
there will be multiple audit teams we
will have
observers from both parties there will
be re-adjudication
and the outcome of this will be the
certified result
so with that i will take any questions
yeah doug
what's two questions are you going to in
your audit distinguish between
uh closed caps by the machines and both
best
absolutely would you actually keep
separate records well
when they made the ballot manifest they
already do that the absentee ballots
which are all hand marker values are
kept separately and they're in smaller
batches
so that will you'll already know those
into the reporting at the end will be
here's mail on absentee here's absentee
in person
here's um actually i don't think
separate that but the batches should be
able to do that
on the final number and then
provisionals is the last one on those
where we can separate those out
and then the second question is are you
inviting a second
recount demand from the trump campaign
by
conducting this audit before under the
law
any person who comes in second by less
than half a percent can
ask for a recount i would hope the
common sense would prevail
and that if it's very close to the first
time the possibility of the computer
recount being
changing the results would be slim to
none yeah
concern i hear all the time is that
i know there's a midnight wednesday
deadline for this to get done the
concern is you know everybody wants the
account to be done
accurately and on time before the
certification deadlines how confident
are you that our county and state
collection officials will be able to get
it done in a timely manner
we're pretty confident we've been doing
running the numbers and we do have
voting works here who has done this
before in fact i got those michigan
numbers from one of their employees
who's here on the ground with us
and they have the expertise in this
we've worked through it we're working
with the counties to make sure they have
the manpower in place
we feel very confident we can get it in
for the 20th but we're aiming for that
18th
and wait let me set a level of
expectation we are not going to be
releasing
the new result counts as they come in we
will be releasing
this is the percent of ballots they've
gotten through this is the percent of
batches they've gotten through
because when you're looking at these
batches it'll be similar to what we saw
before we're going to start with the
absentees because those can be the most
problematic because those have the most
human interaction
and what's going to happen i can
guarantee on day one we're all going to
look at each other and go
oh i don't know if we can make this but
as time passes we get through those
this will be a lot easier and the speed
will pick up as people get more used to
doing
it and then we move the second round of
this we get past the absentees which are
the hand mark paper ones
you're moving to the ballot marking
device ones which are a lot easier
because it's a name
you stack and you go it should be a lot
easier after that but there are
procedures in place we are going to have
what we call sanity checks
throughout to make sure there's nothing
going really crazily off the rails
we have timelines set for everybody and
i feel very i know the small candle will
get through it
and the big counties have resources
we've brought in another logistics firm
to help some of these medium-sized
counties that
have a decent amount size of ballots and
a decent amount of resources
to make sure there's an ability to do
that and yes the costs are built
are going to be borne by the counties
right now we're looking at a way to do
some cost sharing
using the state's federal java dollars
to help take some of that burden off the
counties but that formula has not been
worked out yet
yes
[Music]
there is no process for challenging
values in the audit there is only going
to be the adjudication done
by republican and democrat adjudicators
that the audit team cannot come to a
decision on what that is there is no
ballot challenge
as i understand it these rules are
different but i don't know the recount
rules that well i've been paying a lot
of attention to the audience
everything that these things have to be
sealed or sealed numbers to look at
even when they're doing the the ballot
checks themselves
when they bring in every person who's
moving ballots will not be an auditor
there'll be people who specific jobs for
these things
when the auditors get that they'll have
a valid tally sheet and on that they
will say
box sealed and they already have there's
a record of the box being sealed before
and then we'll reseal the box on the way
back out uh the only
outside difference on that one is if
anything goes to adjudication which
would include
if there's a qualified write-in
presidential if there's a blank ballot
if there's an adjudicated ballot those
will go to the adjudication teams
but they will be kept in a separate
envelope that will be tied back to that
original box of ballots
so they can be married together again
after the adjudication is done
but all of this is documented all of
this is put down on those tally sheets
and all these attracts back to the
master log of the ballot manifest
yes sir
deceased people voting there's been
twice
will the audience
no this is a this is a audit of the
ballots that came through legally
it's going to have to be a post-election
situation to look for individuals who
may have violated the law
and voted double voted and if anybody
has cast a ballot for a dead person
that's a violation of the law however
in georgia the state constitution
requires that there's a privacy of the
ballot so there's no way to tie an
individual ballot back to an individual
human being
because if there was a way to do that
that could lead to a boat buying which
is why you can't take a picture of the
ballot
inside the voting booth until you can
take that to get paid by whomever wants
to pay you
anybody else mark again
i'm going to get you a better mass
mixture so you have to go through all
this
so my understanding is you aren't
comparing
specific balance to specific votes
reported previously we're just starting
over
with a new account we're starting out
with a new count and
in some counties the batches match
the ballot boxes in some counties they
don't which actually is a good thing as
a verification because they're not
aiming at a target
they're not saying oh my gosh we're off
on this it's going to be a cleaner way
to get to a final result
and the main thing we're trying to do is
show that the equipment
print scanned the ballots properly and
the counts we got
were the right counts and the ballots we
have are the back of trail to that
so is the ballot is going to change some
as i have said in every conference when
this has come up yes the outcome will
change slightly at the end more than
likely
at least the the final numbers if we see
something along the lines of 14 to 15
000 we have bigger issues to worry about
but the machines probably didn't count
themselves right
so that's a very important distinction
the point of the audit is to show the
machines
counted the ballots fairly and what we
said from the beginning
every single day we want to get it right
we want to make sure this is accurate we
want to give those people who believe
that there is something flipping a
ballot from a dominion system it's not
happening
and this is the reason a rationale for
an audit to begin with
um i'm not going to speak to the health
concerns of family members of anybody
either elected or on our staff right now
leave them speak to that for themselves
i i'm probably going to get tested but
i'm not going to say well i'm going to
get tested it's not my place to confirm
with this conference i'm talking about
the voting election
um if that's the case then no we're not
impact we have a wide staff
we have outside consultants here and
let's remember something the work of
this recount is being done at the county
level
that is where the boots on the ground
are and as the secretary pointed out
yesterday
the men and women who stood behind him
at that conference where he made this
announcement they're the ones who are
having to do the real work
they have to get up they have to staff
they have to train they can make sure
people are there
they have to make sure they have the six
by ten tables ready to go they have to
make sure they get the notices out
another thing we're asking them to do is
if they can please stream this thing
live so people can see the process
as it happens we are working every day
to be as transparent as we can
my hope and prayer is we cannot move
deadlines we have a federal
drop dead certification deadline and we
have potential backup plans in place to
make sure that
the ballots for january 5th go out for
the acab of military and overseas on
time on saturday the 21st get done this
one
well the uh the folks who are auditing
the most coming out of the dominion
machines
be able to not only eyeball the bubbles
on one side but also
we scan the qr codes there's no need to
rescan qr codes because you're looking
at the name
the word donald trump is there the word
joe biden is there the word judge
jorgensen is there that is what they are
stacking they're not looking at bubbles
or anything on that
on the ballot marking device created uh
ballots
well the whole point is if you um count
it out it comes out about the same that
kind of
speaks for itself that's the whole point
of the audit network
just going back to yesterday and
starting this full
statewide audit um to accomplish that
did
you
set the risk limit to zero there's two
ways to do this
if you go back and listen to the
individual um
i don't that's what's the good word to
say academics who discovered this this
is math you discover math you don't
invent math um
they basically said if you get to a
point we're pulling 10 to 15 percent of
the ballots you need to go ahead and
move to a full hand retaliate
they have said that on the record as
earth slaves last week you can check
with monica childers
from uh voting works who knows about
these things much more specifically than
i do
we could have said it at zero we've got
it i mean i'll get let's give some
perspective
if you set it at 10 we would have had to
pull a little i think nearly 1.5 million
balance if you set it at five percent
you'd have to pull 2.5 million balance
it is just functionally and logistically
easier to go
i'm going to do every single batch thing
pull number 17 from batch 37 do that all
around the county and try to keep up
with all those things
this is functionally an easier thing to
do even though it may not sound like it
it is a lot easier to do we if we want
to we can set it to zero it will
absolutely get us there but the
realities of the way risk limiting audit
works is
and even the discoverers of the science
behind this said
if you get past 10 or 15 you may as well
do the whole thing which is kind of what
we're looking at here
and it was part of the discussions we
had pre any
in the trump campaign as i said at the
beginning of this conference we would
have chosen to do this had biden been
the one
who was behind by 14 000 votes because
let me guarantee you
of all the people who are yelling right
now about these machines and these
margins being close
that are supporting donald trump if the
situation was reversed
the same thing would be happening the
other side i think we've all seen that
over the last few years
that social media puts us into our own
bubbles where
facts sometimes get a little diluted
because we want to believe and see
the outcome we want because it's very
important because to many people
and and even to me to a degree this is
the fate of the republic in their minds
they've been told it's the most
important election of your lives we've
heard that every year since i've been
alive
it always seems to be ratcheting up that
way yes ma'am
in an abundance of caution we will
always make sure that our office and our
employees are secure
um i i know that there was a situation
yesterday with the wsb tv reporter and
his cameraman
who are put into potentially harm's way
and that's a terrible thing that
shouldn't happen
and we shouldn't be in a situation where
anybody from the right or the left
puts out the idea that it's okay to try
to intimidate people or change those
minds
this office has a responsibility and one
responsibility only which is the voters
of georgia to give them the right and
accurate result to make sure
that the intent of the voters and the
will of the people have been met
regardless of output yes
i guess what would you say to somebody
who
doesn't follow politics doesn't follow
muslims
doesn't necessarily watch this process
what would you say to somebody
to have them trust that at the end of
the
it's going to be difficult if anybody
doesn't follow anything
to convince them we've got a lot of
safeguards in place
we have a lot of processes in place
there's security and all
all cyber security is one of the things
we're talking about here begins with
physical security
to get into our voter registration
system you have to have a unique user id
a unique password you have to go through
multi-factor um
we have the pull pads come in
that are get the that data to check
people in our bmds and our scanners
never touch the internet the election
management systems that are used to
tally and do the final tallities
never touch the internet they're all air
gaps we have
four voter registration system we have
an albert sensor we have partnerships
with department of homeland security we
have our own outside vendors to go in
and look at penetration testing and make
sure there's nothing happening
and look for bad actors and look for
bots it's always changing
every day this office spends a heck of a
lot of time
on making sure that the equipment
involved is secure we speak ah we spend
a heck of a lot of time with the
counties
training people the decentralized nature
of votes in georgia the security measure
in and of itself it's 159 counties
there's not a single target
and one of the situations we're worried
about going forward in the january 5
election
is that we've gone from 50 state targets
to one
so we fully anticipate that the
potential threat level in the state will
increase
and while i'm at it there's another
thing we need to talk about that is
going back to the nature of our law when
it comes to registration
um there's been discussion about people
coming in from out of state andrew yang
being the most famous
to come and help georgia see the life
and do the right thing
i want to remind everybody in order to
have the ability to register to vote in
georgia
you have to be a georgia resident which
means you have to believe that you're
staying in georgia
you can't be a canvasser for bloomberg
you can't be a canvasser for the koch
brothers and decide hey i'm going to
vote here while i'm here
if you do that and you leave the
attorney general office reminds us of
this yesterday they put it online
it is a felony that is charged after 10
years
and i think a hundred thousand dollar
fine
let me be clear about this if you want
to move to georgia and be part of the
number one state in america to do
business we are happy to have you
it's great to have you come in but if
you were here for the sole sake of
politics
if you voted for senate in one state and
moved here to another state i know
that's another thing that could
potentially be
built before the courts because you've
already cast a vote for a body that's
going to be seeded in january
don't game our system
the secretary of state's office will
stand with the attorney general's office
and local da's if you're gaming our
system
come here campaign go door-to-door it's
your first amendment right but don't
try to game our system are you aware
today no i think they're going through
training they're going to read
like i said the final instructions just
went out so it'd be difficult
we've given them a lot of things they
have to print this is a very open
process there's very large signage so
they can see what's going on
we know there's going to be observers we
know there's interest everybody has a
little bit of time to make sure that
they need to make sure the observer's
there they need to follow the rules on
this stuff
and i feel confident that our counties
who have executed everything so well
since june and frankly 95 percent of
them did a great regime
we had a few i'll remind everybody again
we have 70 percent of the issues in june
we're in one
county and we saw some issues with them
like i said i had to go after the
georgia game to state farm myself
because they uploaded
their results without doing the
reconciliation it's silly things like
this
that undermine confidence is why you
have to follow the processes and
procedures we lay down
it's boring it's tedious but it is
vitally important
yeah doug you said that human beings
basically are the weak link here
uh how do you prevent the folks who are
doing the hand down from becoming the
weakling
another they're going to be the weak
link there's no way to prevent it
necessarily all you can do is try to
mitigate it
by doing them in batches by keeping the
sanity checks in as we go to make sure
that things are looking
relatively normal that's how we're going
to be able to look for those kind of
things but if there's something that's
way wackadood out of place we'll try to
address it as it comes like i said
they're they're going to make mistakes
they're going to make more mistakes than
computers but there are people out there
that just fundamentally will not believe
the outcome unless they say
i don't trust those computers so i need
a human to
that's a hypothetical i'm not willing to
change this yet all right
anybody else yes
[Music]
no no the audit shall begin tomorrow at
9 a.m if you're putting stuff in boxes
to go to the place you're going to give
your county you're starting your audit
this is this is more essentially we
don't want people waiting until monday
we want to get it get get the get the
show on the road because
we we're burning daylight every hour
this is an audit that has moved to a
point of a hand retaliate
it's a re-tally it is not a recount
because that is a separate statute
all right is that it all right thanks
y'all